GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> ALL RIGHT, CHECK IT OUT,
CHECK IT OUT.
LOOKING LIKE LIVE AT A BAHAMAS
COURTHOUSE WHERE DISGRACED FTX
FOUNDER SAM BANKMAN-FRIED COULD
COME OUT ANY MOMENT.
THE FALLEN CRYPTO KING ARRESTED
IN THE BAHAMAS.
CHARGES INCLUDE WIRE FRAUD,
MONEY LAUNDERING, AND CONSPIRACY
TO VIOLATE CAMPAIGN LAWS.
PROSECUTORS OUTLINING THEIR CASE
ACCUSING HIM OF TRYING TO BY
INFLUENCE, POLITICAL INFLUENCE,
WITH STOLEN MONEY.
>> ALL OF THIS DIRTY MONEY WAS
USED IN SERVICE OF
BANKMAN-FRIED'S DESIRE TO BUY
BIPARTISAN INFLUENCE AND IMPACT
THE DIRECTION OF PUBLIC POLICY
IN WASHINGTON.
IT'S SO HARD TO COMPARE THESE
THINGS, BUT IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THAT BY ANYONE, THIS IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST FINANCIAL FRAUDS IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> LAWMAKERS WERE SUPPOSED TO
HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THE
FORMER BILLION TODAY ON CAPITOL
HILL, BUT HE JUST GOT BUSTED
HOURS BEFORE HE WAS SET TO
TESTIFY.
INSTEAD CONGRESS GRILLING FTX'S
NEWEST CEO ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
>> THE FTX COLLAPSE APPEARS TO
BE IN THE HANDS OF A SMALL GROUP
OF GROSSLY INEXPERIENCED,
UNSOPHISTICATED INDIVIDUALS.
THIS IS REAL OLD-FASHIONED
EMBEZZLEMENT.
>> I THINK EVERYBODY LOVED THE
EXCITING IDEA OF A POLITICALLY
PROGRESSIVE, SMART ENTREPRENEUR,
GOING TO REIMAGINE CAPITALISM.
I'M GLAD TO SEE IT'S FINALLY
UNRAVELED.
>> WHAT YOU HAVE IS A CRYPTO
CASINO.
>> I'M SO DEEPLY TROUBLED TO
LEARN HOW COMMON IT WAS FOR
BANKMAN-FRIED AND FTX EMPLOYEES
TO STEAL FROM THE COOKIE JAR OF
CUSTOMER FUNDS TO FINANCE THEIR
LAVISH LIFESTYLE.
>> THE FORMER BILLIONAIRE JUST
WOULDN'T STOP TALKING TO PRESS
OUTLETS AND GIVING INTERVIEWS.
JUST YESTERDAY HE WAS PREDICTING
THIS --
>> ARE YOU WORRIED YOU MIGHT BE
DETAINED IF YOU STEPPED FOOT
INTO THE U.S.?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE I WOULD BE,
BUT I HAVEN'T DONE A DEEP DIVE
INTO THAT.
AT SOME POINT IT'S SOMETHING I
HAVE TO THINK HARD ABOUT.
>> JUDGE, THE CRIMINAL COMPLAINT
CAME OUT AFTER THE SEC
COMPLAINT,,000 IN THE BAHAMIAN
COURT REPORTER.
COURT.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN THEM ACT THIS
QUICKLY.
THEY SAY THERE ARE 1 MILLION
CREDITORS.
THAT IS INCREDIBLE.
THAT IS A HUGE FRAUD.
AND SO YOU SAY TO YOURSELF, WHY
WOULD THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT THAT
TAKES MONTHS AND MONTHS AND
MONTHS, ESPECIALLY IN ECONOMIC
CRIMES, MOVE SO QUICKLY?
WELL, YOU COULD ARGUE THEY WERE
WORRIED HE MIGHT ABSCOND, BUT AT
THE SAME TIME HE WAS WILLING TO
TESTIFY.
AS ANY PROSECUTOR KNOWS, IF
YOU'RE GOING TO TRIAL, WHAT YOU
WANT MORE THAN ANYTHING IS PRIOR
STATEMENTS OF A DEFENDANT.
AND THIS INDIVIDUAL HAS
TESTIFIED FOR WEEKS ON END, AND
MADE INCRIMINATING STATEMENTS.
NONE OF THOSE STATEMENTS WILL BE
INADMISSIBLE.
HE SWORE TO TELL THE TRUTH.
THEY ARE UNDER OATH.
THERE'S NO MIRANDA REQUIRED, NO
CUSTODIAL CUSTODY ISSUE.
THOSE STATEMENTS ARE GOLDEN.
WHY STOP HIM FROM TESTIFYING IN
FRONT OF CONGRESS TODAY?
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT
INFORMATION TO COME OUT THAT'S
POLITICAL.
LOOK, HE WAS A NUMBER ONE DONOR
TO DEMOCRAT POLITICAL CAUSES.
HIS MOTHER APPARENTLY RAN A
MAJOR DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGN FUND.
HE WINED AND DINED POLITICAL
PEOPLE TRYING TO INFLUENCE THE
REGULATORS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, HE GAVE TO
REPUBLICANS TOO.
BUT I THINK THIS WAS AN ATTEMPT
TO LITERALLY SHUT DOWN THE
TRUTH, BECAUSE THIS IS THE ONE
CHANCE THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE
IN CONGRESS SAYING AND WHO DID
YOU GIVE MONEY TO, WHAT
COMMITTEE ARE THEY ON, WHAT DID
YOU EXPECT FROM THEM?
JUST ONE MORE THING.
THERE WERE RED FLAGS ALL ALONG.
TERRY DUFFY SAID THIS THING
RIGHT FROM THE BEGINNING WAS
FRAUDULENT.
HE USED MONEY TO INVEST FOR
HIMSELF.
HE GAVE HIS GIRLFRIEND MONEY,
ALAMEDA.
WHY IS SHE NOT A CODEFENDANT?
WHY?
MAYBE BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING TO
GET HER TO TESTIFY.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I DON'T THINK
THEY NEED HER TO TESTIFY.
HE GAVE MONEY TO HER.
THAT MONEY IS GONE.
EXPLAIN WHAT YOU DID WITH THAT
MONEY.
YOU'VE GOT TWO AT THE TOP.
YOU DON'T NEED ANYONE ELSE AS
FAR AS I'M CONCERNED.
THERE WERE POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS, BUYING OUT THE
BAHAMAS, THE REAL ESTATE.
YOU KNOW, THE WHOLE SMELL OF IT
JUST STINKS.
IN THE END, THERE WILL BE A
CONVICTION.
HE WILL SPEND HIS LIFE IN JAIL.
SHAME ON HIM AND HIS PARENTS WHO
KNEW SO MUCH MORE.
>> INTERESTING, JESSICA, ABOUT
THE PARENTS, THE PARENTS SAID
THEY WERE WORRIED HIS LEGAL FEES
WILL WIPE THEM OUT.
THE KID -- WELL, NOT A KID.
HE'S A MAN.
THEIR CHILD DEFRAUDED ALL THESE
PEOPLE AND WIPED THEM OUT.
>> POTENTIALLY THERE'S A BIG
MANSION HE BOUGHT FOR THEM IN
THE BAHAMAS THAT THEY SAY THEY
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT.
HE WAS PROBABLY TAKING THEM FOR
A RIDE, THE SAME WAY HE WAS TO
EVERYBODY ELSE WHO WAS INVESTING
IN THIS SCHEME, IS WHAT WE HAVE
TO CALL IT AT THIS POINT.
YOU CAN'T EVEN SAY IT'S A
COMPANY.
TO THE JUDGE'S POINT, THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT WAS CLEAR THIS
WAS AN ATTEMPT TO BUY BIPARTISAN
INFLUENCE.
IF YOU WANT TO BLAME SOMEONE
ABOUT THE FACT WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHICH REPUBLICANS HE
GAVE TO, WE HAVE TWO NAMES, BUT
THE NUMBER OF THEM -- LET'S TALK
ABOUT CITIZENS UNITED, HOW IT
MAKES IT A SYSTEM IN WHICH YOU
CAN GIVE THROUGH DARK MONEY
GROUPS ESSENTIALLY UNLIMITED
MONEY.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED THERE.
TWO THINGS THAT I FIND REALLY
INTERESTING.
ONE, WHAT ROLE DID THE
GOVERNMENT PLAY IN THIS?
THEY WANT TO REGULATE THE CRYPTO
WORLD.
WAS HE TRYING TO BUY INFLUENCE
TO MAKE SURE CRYPTO WOULD NEVER
BE REGULATED.
SECOND THING, WE HAVEN'T SEEN
SOMEONE, A FINANCIAL CRIME
COMMITTED OF THIS LEVEL BY A
MILLENNIAL, SOMEONE ADDICTED TO
BEING ONLINE.
HE WAS EVEN ON TWITTER
YESTERDAY, GIVING INTERVIEWS,
RIGHT, LEFT AND CENTER.
IT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
LANDSCAPE FOR THIS.
BERNIE MADOFF, IF HE WANTED TO
TALK TO THE PRESS, MEET ME AT A
DARK DINER, I'LL TALK TO YOU
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
THIS KID HAS BEEN PLASTERING IT
EVERYWHERE.
SEEMS LIKE IT WILL BE A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT DYNAMIC IN
TERMS OF THE PROSECUTION.
>> JESSE, WHAT GOOD IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF
REGULATIONS IF THIS CAN HAPPEN
TO PEOPLE?
LACKS TIME HE APPEARED BEFORE
MAXINE WATERS' COMMITTEE SHE
APPEARED TO BLOW HIM A KISS.
>> SHE DIDN'T APPEAR TO.
SHE DID.
I SAW IT.
SHE BLEW A KISS.
THAT'S WHY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAD TO PUT OUT THIS FIRE,
BECAUSE THIS GUY WAS ON A REHAB
TOUR.
EVERY TIME HE OPENED HIS MOUTH
HE WAS HUMILIATING THE
DEMOCRATS.
HE WAS HUMILIATING BILL CLINTON,
THE IRS, WALL STREET, THE SEC.
EVERYBODY WAS IN BED WITH THIS
GUY.
FOR A MONTH AND A HALF HE WENT
OUT AND TALKED MORE THAN FAUCI
AND EXPOSED THE CODE.
THE CODE IS I'M GOING TO SAY
WHATEVER THE LEFT WANTS TO HEAR
AND I'M GOING TO SHOVEL MONEY
DOWN THEIR THROAT.
SO THEY LET ME DO WHAT I WANT.
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO TALK
ABOUT THE CODE.
IT'S A SILENT CODE.
IT'S CALLED GREEN WASHING, WOKE
WASHING, WHATEVER YOU CALL IT,
AND THAT BLOWS UP THE WHOLE
SYSTEM.
IT'S LIKE BRIBERY, GREASING
POLITICIANS, BUT HE PUT IT OUT
THERE WAY TOO GRAPHICALLY.
SO HE HAD TO GO DOWN.
HE STOLE MONEY FROM PEOPLE, AND
THEN HE DONATED IT TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
SO BIDEN HAD TO BUST HIS SECOND
BIGGEST MEGADONOR.
IT WAS A PUMP AND DUMP.
HE WAS PUMPING AND DUMPING.
THE DEMOCRATS PUMPED AND DUMPED
HIM.
THEY LEGITIMATIZED HIM.
HE'S GOT HIS COMPANY'S NAME ON
ARENAS, UP THERE WITH BILL AND
CELEBRITIES NOW.
THERE'S COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
HE WENT DOWN HARD.
YOU CAN SEE THIS FRAUD A MILE
AWAY.
GREG AND I TALK ABOUT THIS ALL
THE TIME, WHETHER IT'S AVENATTI,
SAMMIE STICKY FINGERS, PINCHING
BAGS AT EVERY AIRPORT IN THE
NATION.
IT'S A BIG ADVERTISEMENT FOR
SCAM ARTISTS.
WE SEE IT, BUT YOU CAN'T SAY IT.
IF YOU SAY IT, YOU'RE A BIGOT.
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT.
THEN THE LEFT, THEY DON'T WANT
TO HEAR IT, BECAUSE THEY'RE
GETTING RICH OFF OF IT.
THEY'RE GETTING, YOU KNOW, GOOD
PRESS OFF OF IT.
SO WHATEVER.
NOW HE WANTS TO GET OUT OF
PRISON BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
GIVING HIM A VEGAN DIET.
>> YEAH.
>> LISTEN, THAT'S NOT GOING TO
GET YOUR BAIL REDUCED.
HE'S A FLIGHT RISK ALREADY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE COLON CANCER,
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, BECAUSE YOU
DON'T LIKE THE FOOD, SORRY, YOU
HAVE TO STAY IN JAIL WITH SOME
BAHAMIAN KNUCKLEHEADS.
>> JUST TWO WEEKS AGO HE WAS IN
FRONT OF A BIG "NEW YORK TIMES"
AUDIENCE BEING INTERVIEWED, AND
THE AUDIENCE WAS LAUGHING WHEN
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED WAS MAKING
JOKES ABOUT, OH, MAYBE MY LAWYER
SAID I SHOULDN'T DO THIS.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS SO FUNNY.
>> HOW QUICKLY THE TIDE HAS
TURNED, DANA.
>> RED TIDE.
>> GIVE HIM LONG PANTS.
I'VE SEEN HIS KNEES MORE THAN
I'VE SEEN MY OWN.
THESE BIG MEATY HOOKS, SITTING
THERE WITH SHORTS.
HE'S SLIGHTLY BETTER DRESSED
THAN JOHN FETTERMAN, BUT I WON'T
GO THAT FAR.
THE TIMING IS SUSPICIOUS.
YOU KNOW, BEFORE HE SINGS, HE
GETS ARRESTED.
IF HE ENDS UP DEAD IN JAIL WE'LL
KNOW ONE THING, THAT HE
DEFINITELY SWINDLED HILLARY
CLINTON.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE THESE RED
FLAGS.
ONE OF THE RED FLAGS, I'M SORRY,
WE GOT TO TALK ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
LOOK.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU CAN JUDGE A BOOK BY ITS
COVER.
YOU BROUGHT UP SAM BRYNTON.
HE HAD THE VOICE OF A CREEPY
WIND-UP DOLL.
HE LOOKS LIKE ONE OF THE
FORGOTTEN THREE STOOGES.
IF HE TRANSITIONS, PERHAPS HE
COULD BE ON "THE VIEW."
IT'S A LESSON, REITERATING WHAT
YOU SAID, IT'S A LESSON FOR
EVERYONE.
THE CELEBRITIES GET SUED?
THEY SHOULD.
THEY PUSHED IT.
>> TOM BRADY?
>> EXCEPT FOR TOM BRADY, BECAUSE
HE'S AN AMERICAN HERO.
BUT ANYWAY, COMPASSIONATE
INVESTING IS USUALLY A CYNICAL
COVER.
REPUBLICANS FALL FOR THIS LESS
THAN DEMOCRATS, BECAUSE WE --
YOU CAN'T SUCKER PEOPLE THAT
KNOW ECONOMICS INTO A BAD DEAL.
I WON'T EVEN BE TRICKED INTO A
GOOD DEAL.
LIKE I'M STILL NOT DOING THE
401(K) UNTIL I SEE SOME REAL
RESULTS.
>> YOUR MATTRESS MUST BE
STUFFED.
>> IT'S GETTING